children of course at that time should
have been at the heart of decisions that
the government was making when it came
to covert and it came to the
restrictions in schools and and how
children should be taught
um do you think children were at the
heart of these discussions
well I'm sad to say I don't think so I'm
the former Children's Commission now as
Children's Commission during that period
of time and I spent an awful lot of time
putting forward
the kind of policies that needed to be
thought about
um if children were going to get the
support they needed during this you know
very very uncertain time for them let's
remember children were out of school for
about six months uh most children we
know that since then levels of anxiety
and mental health has plummeted so
children are living with the impact of
what happened during that time right now
today but it's very clear to me that
children weren't given the priority they
should have been there wasn't enough
discussion about the impact of decisions
on children's well-being and as a
consequence it feels that they were
quite overlooked often in terms of the
big decisions that were made
and when you look at the actual
decisions that were made do are you
confident that science was used as the
basis for decisions or or now looking at
this does it appear that politics was
what was driving a lot of it yes well it
does quite appear that you know this was
a heavy dose of political political
expediency here
um look the the the first shock was when
schools didn't open in June of the year
and pubs shops theme parks and zoos did
that was a clear indication that
children's well-being wasn't at the top
of the agenda it went on in terms of
various decisions over Mass over the
rule of six how many people could meet
together which was hopeless for large
families it meant that many children
couldn't see their friends or their
grandparents for many many months but in
Scotland they thought of that and they
allowed children under 12 to not be
counted for that rule of six sometimes
it was as simple as that and of course
we saw
um closures of schools reopening
closures all On a Carousel of decisions
which do seem to have
um really played into Political
decisions at that time rather than a
constant National effort towards
children
do you think children were let down
I think they were let down I think they
were often forgotten sometimes
overlooked
um you know if there's an emergency of
this nature in our country a national
threat we should all think it's the
right thing to put children young people
at the heart of our consideration
they're the ones that need the greatest
protection and they're the ones who are
likely to have the greatest impact in
the future and I don't think in this
country we did that I don't think we
took the decisions that some other
countries did
um to offer that support and reassurance
to children
why do you think that was why do you
think we differed so much
I do think that it comes down to how
much of a political priority children
are for a country
um there are some countries that Define
themselves about what they can offer to
children and whilst there are many good
things of course that we offer children
government intervenes with in this
country there isn't the sense that
actually children are at the Forefront
there isn't the understanding always of
what those needs are and there isn't
that voice at the cabinet table often
that's saying what are we going to do
for children here that's strong enough
to actually get the backing of the top
I wonder if you think looking at the
messages between Mr Hancock and Gavin
Williamson cracking announcement today
what a bunch of absolute asses the
teaching unions are I know they really
really do just hate work I mean it's
juvenile it's unprofessional
um stereotyping of teachers do you think
anything has changed since then
in terms of opinion towards uh towards
the sector I mean I would hope so and
there's been lots of reassurances today
that actually you know you do understand
and people do understand the importance
and the important role of teachers which
of course they should but I think it
gives an indication of how quickly
children's issues and the well-being of
young people can be swept aside some of
it you know as you say in terms of uh
juvenile
messages there but at the heart of this
do we really understand what it takes to
give children the best possible start in
life that's needed and do is the country
think that's one of our top five
priorities I don't think we're there yet
and just to be clear do you think either
Gavin Williamson or man Hancock were
there at the time for children oh no I
don't I think you can see that from the
messages clearly Gavin Williamson is
saying that he wanted to keep schools
open but I think what this needs is a
national effort we didn't see that
National effort and we aren't seeing
those in those WhatsApp messages today
okay and Longfield the former children's
commissioner for England are very good
to talk to you today thanks a lot for
joining us